I guess there's more to talk about
what's a Star Wars trailer because it's
been a day everything else is just like
alright Star Wars trailer it's fun Star
Wars trailer and that's what Star Wars
trailers are supposed to be I know some
people aren't keen on the name but I
think the name is fine because one every
Star Wars name is stupid like they'll
suck Phantom Menace Attack of the Clones
well who doesn't think of send in the
clowns who doesn't think of invisible
Dennis the Menace when they think of
Phantom Menace even Empire Strikes Back
sucks by title anyway the movie is
[ __ ] superb like if this movie was
called the first-order Strikes Back no
everyone would be like [ __ ] that stupid
titles that the first-order Strikes Back
is no better than Empire Strikes Back
but the rise of Skywalker at least gives
you that Luther how the [ __ ] and how the
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] and so I enjoy that
because that's part of the Star Wars
experience is theorized annoying how is
it possible what's going on so kind of
get that with the title and I also
understand a lot of this shit's gonna be
like fan bait service because everything
in episode 9 is gonna be reactionary
right like just like the force awakens
was reactionary to Star Wars before the
force awakens so it was like the
prequels came out and a lot of fans were
like [ __ ] the prequels so Abrams was
like hey so force awakens I remember
Star Wars before the prequels come back
now episode 8 came out and Abrams gonna
be like hey I remember anything before
episode hey come back see look at all
the fanservice Star Wars as we knew Star
Wars it's no longer Star Wars it's not
gonna be that any more but I can at
least have fun with what am i baby I
just say I am though I just kind of roll
with life like I would love to go back
to a time where I'm a kid again don't
have any responsibilities and I don't
pay taxes but that's not the reality I
live in I live in this reality so I just
press forward enjoying this reality I'll
try to press forward enjoy episode 9 but
that's not really what this is about
this is about the Palpatine thing the
Palpatine thing is when I heard it in
the trailer the one I was talking about
it my video I was like it's not gonna be
in the movies gonna be like a vision or
something like that they're just doing
that to hook people and then people in
my comment section were like nah like at
Star Wars Celebration Ian McDermott came
out and I guess Abram said Palpatine's
gonna be in the movie like as Palpatine
implying not just a vision but like the
guy I don't like that just simply put I
just don't like that I don't like
anything about that because everything
about Palpatine being in episode nine as
Palpatine just minimizes Palpatine and
everyone
found him like everything that happened
it just minimizes all of it like Star
Wars is no stranger to death retcons
Darth Maul Boba Fett but I I understand
those whoa but that was pretty sweet
you got the stupidest death ever so I
kind of get it the thing I miss most
about Boba Fett being alive now is the
fact that I can't say the stupidest
deaths in movies are someone being Boba
Fett 'add cuz I guess he's alive so I
call it washed now cuz that was dumb too
so I get that Darth Maul was a prop
Darth Maul was just a prop for a fight
in Phantom Menace so what was the guy
behind all that what was the guy behind
the animal and they kind of delve into
that in a series and I do like that
about Darth Maul there was more to tell
there than what we got but Palpatine
there's not we saw the guys life we saw
the guy rule we saw the guy die we saw
him get murdered by his apprentice a
fine death to be sure any Spartan would
jerk off to that death because that's a
good death and it can turn good through
Palpatine down the thing and killed him
but now I guess he's alive this is all
hypothetically if he's alive if he's not
some force of vision or something
there's a lot more going if you can hear
that I apologize it's spring it happened
Palpatine story's done we saw him rise
we saw him fall we saw him die and it's
done Bo on top what makes Palpatine
great is that there was nothing written
there's no prophecy about the guy if I
say anything in this video where
someone's like will in the books and the
extended lore [ __ ] off with that [ __ ] I
mean I don't mean to be mean you could
stay but I'm saying I don't give a [ __ ]
cuz I don't I just stick to the movies
at this point other than the Darth Maul
thing Darth Maul coming back I was
intrigued and I looked into it and I
liked it I liked what I found and I
think the movie is in the lore should
stick to the mo you shouldn't have to go
outside the movies to get everything
happening in the movies so that being
said Palpatine there was nothing written
no prophecy that was like oh this guy is
going to avenge the Sith and take over
the galaxy now there was just his rule
of two thing and he was like you know
what I think I'm gonna rule it all
[ __ ] and that makes him cool but like
why is he the guy if he's in this movie
why isn't it like Darth Bane he seemed
like he was a pretty big deal why isn't
he the guy coming back Darth Bane could
be like you already met my father's
brothers nephews cousins former roommate
how useless was he now I have come back
but I don't get why why Palpatine and
the reason is because it's his fan
service people love Palpatine and he's
been in all the other saga
he was in the prequels original trilogy
and I guess now he's in this and there
is the argument after Palpatine told
Anakin that Darth Plagueis learned how
to cheat death
he said he taught his apprentice
everything he knew implying that he was
the apprentice and even after that after
Palpatine implied to Anakin he knew how
to cheat death he then blatantly told
Anakin well I don't actually know only
one knew it was Darth Plagueis but I'm
sure if we work together we can discover
the secret translation I don't [ __ ]
know and if he did know what did
Plagueis teach him how to come back from
being vaporized because let's face it he
was [ __ ] vaporized there was also the
argument the possibility the theory that
he could be a force ghost which I'm not
gonna lie that kind of flies in the face
of the whole good guys get force ghost
but bad guys don't think I know in
extended lore cartoons books animations
whatever the crazier things have
happened then bad guys coming back in
one way shape or form but at least and
this is my personal thing I totally get
that but in my head Canon I've always
been able to be like yeah but in the
movies good guys get first ghosts bad
guys do not and that totally makes sense
to me because bad guys are all about you
know the here and now the dark sides all
about the gratification of the here and
now in this life you get all this
wonderful power and force lightning now
but when you die you don't get to live
on as a force ghost whereas if you're a
good guy living a let's face it more
boring life after you die you do get to
live on as a forest ghost
I like that dynamic and no matter what
anything else has done I've always been
able to be like a in the movies that's
how that is and now I might not be able
to no sex for me but if he comes back as
the force goes - who is he coming back
to that's the question I imagined to be
kylo Ren I know naturally it's like his
right his granddaughter or whatever but
I imagine it would be kylo Ren because
it's like I knew your grandfather we did
great things together which also makes
me think like they're bringing Palpatine
back because Snoke died I feel like
whatever Palpatine does in this one -
whispering - kylo ren's
ear that would have been Snoke go Ryan
Johnson killed him so now we meet
Palpatine back we need someone to
whisper at the dark side into his ear
might as well be someone we know cuz it
can't be someone new you can't just
bring in some new bad guy and kylo Ren
even Darth Vader the bad guy I root for
is most interesting when he has someone
over here pulling him to the dark side
and someone over here pulling him to the
light side he can't get that now cuz
Snoke died oh my god I said I really
[ __ ] [ __ ] up didn't it but really my
point to all of it is I don't want him
to come back because there's something
wonderful about just a period at the end
of it
closing the book saying hey that
chapters done that bad guy was defeated
my concern is if you bring the big evil
from the previous Star Wars saga in fact
the previous two Star Wars sagas the two
trilogies the previous six movies you
bring the big evil back for this trilogy
and there will never be a feeling of
closure because he was defeated before
he was taken down so if he or whatever
evil he kylo Ren whoever is taken down
this time then will doubt it will never
feel like oh yeah they were defeated
you'll always feel like well they'll be
back next time possibly and we need that
feeling of closure and fulfillment
bringing them back might actually
compromise that and who knows an
execution
they might just pull it off it might be
amazing but that's for right now it kind
of seems like a TV show that had a great
first couple seasons then as the show
went on the quality started to decline
so in the later seasons when it's in its
dip they bring a character back from the
earlier seasons that fans really love to
be like hey we got that thing you really
love that characters we're still cool
really gives the illusion of quality
what in reality is just giving people
familiarity or at least someone they
love kind of feels like that right now
all right so there's my thoughts on
Palpatine possibly coming back as a
vision force ghost clone or him in the
physical because he lived through
vaporization what do you think how do
you think he's gonna come back and do
you think he's gonna come back at all
and do you think he should whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]